hey everybody it's Mike for your here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmfc control
ps.l2-3.9.1 screen individuals prior to
authorizing access to organizational
systems containing cui
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of the
cmmc dfars and nist sp800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you've found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so you're hired here's the
password to the next major piece of
military fear gear yikes okay so this is
an interesting control to try and
quantify because essentially the idea
here is that you should not just
randomly give someone access to cui all
right that would be bad that makes
enough sense to me but then they really
stop pretty short of telling you what
the qualifications should be or criteria
because of course every company and
situation is different all they're
really after here is what is the process
you use and can you show an assessor
what that looks like it better be
documented and formalized so they know
it's a repeatable hey here's yet another
hint you probably have it on have a
policy on that so if you don't have a
policy on that it's time to break out
the sharp pencil or just dial our phone
number and we'll hook you up with a
policy
honestly I think it's a little a little
bit goofy because screening doesn't
really specify anything nothing specific
like a background check uh no criminal
background check so why does this
actually increase security highly
interesting to me but who cares what I
think right because at the end of the
day uh it's really the assessors and
what they want and what they want is a
process not necessarily anything
specific in that process so hey fair
enough let's go see exactly what they
want on this one only one assessment
Point here which is determine if
individuals are screened prior to
authorizing access to organizational
systems containing cui uh if you were to
give a sample answer we would say hey
the organization utilizes a screening
and training process which includes
criminal background checks interviews
and drug tests prior to allowing system
access
so uh if you need more help on this uh
the good news is that an on-call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who've had this dfar's nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped into their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day and
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance service roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you